♪~
わっ！
ひ〜！
痛っ！
(フッ)
こんにちは
冒険家兼…あ、なにこれ？
私、昔、スライムカレーという物を紹介した事があると思うんですよ
青色のカレーライスみたいなの食べた事があるんですけども
も〜、なんか〜、
ま、味は美味しかったよ
味は美味しかったんですけど
やっぱ、こう、なんか色がすごくて
だがしかし、カレー業界は日々進歩するもので
こちら！
スライムカレー　どくけし味
スライムカレー　ざっそう味
スライムカレー　やくそう味
でございます。
マジか…
噂にあることは聞いてたんですけども
いざ目の前にするとすごいね
こちら緑色のカレー
こちら赤色のカレー
で、こっちが青色のカレーです
これ大丈夫かなぁ？
大丈夫かなぁ？
これ、やばいなぁ…
いや、これ、マジか〜！！
顎、痒くなってきた
今回、僕がしたいのは、
このね、珍しくも色のあるカレーライス、
というのが、ちょっと気になってしまいました
ひょっとしたら、混ぜた方が美味しそうな色になるかもしれない
…かもしれない
どうかな？
ちょっとわかんない
よくわかんないですけども
とりあえず、今日の夜ご飯になるんで
ちょっと、実際にスライムカレーを三色混ぜて
どんな味になるのか？
そして、どんな色になるのか？
実際にやってみようと思います。
では、行こう！
OK！レディースアンドジェントルメン
ひとまず開けて行こう。
そう、どれも普通なんだよね
OK !
普通のカレールーです
レンジでチンのライス買ってきたので
早速、レンジチンしてきます
チン！
久しぶりにレンジ使う感はある
３分か
いいだろう！
で、レンチンしている間に
カレールーを温めます。
しっかりゆすぎましょう。
OK !
OK ! Nice Fire !
準備完了！
あとは、これがあったかくなってきたら
スライムカレーを3つぶち込んで完璧です。
OK！結構グツってきたんで、カレー入れまっしょう！
調子に乗りました。普通に入れましょう。
５分間沸騰させて完成です
その間にレンジでチンしたライスを
容器に移しましょう
ヤベェ…
一個でよかった…
そろそろいいんじゃないすかね？
もういいでしょう！
ちょっと、色、見ていきましょう！
まずはお前だ！
もう、色がね…
あっつ！！
色がすごいんすよ、多分。
あ！赤だ！
嘘じゃん…
う〜わっ！マジか、これ。
これがカレーなんですよ
次はこれだな。
あ〜、これ見覚えのある
見覚えのある色ですね
こんな色です
うわ〜、なんか思い出してきた〜。
じゃ、これがグリーンか
うわっ！グロっ！
グリーンが一番タチ悪いか、これ。
グリーンカレー、こんなのです
こ、これです
食欲を一切感じられません
このまま混ぜちゃってももったいないので
まずはグリーンから。
いただきます
くそぅ！
うまいんだよ
色がこうなんだけど美味しんだよ
じゃ、次、レッド！
いただきます
チクショウ、うまい。
ブルー、行きます。
これがね、一番衝撃的だよね
味は知ってるけどさ
無駄にまろやかで美味しいです！
多分ね、美術的に考えると黒なんだよね
行きますよ、行きますよ、行きますよ！
これが混ぜ合わせる前の姿です
じゃ、ちょっと混ぜていって何色になるのでしょうか
うわっ！うわっ！ヤバイ！
何？
これ、カレーと思う人いる？
う〜わ、ヤバイ。
おめでとうございます
俺、今からこれ食べるんだからね？
色、ヤバイでしょ！
いやいやいやいや
スライム沼カレーです
だた、大事なのは味の方です
じゃ、早速いただきます
めちゃくちゃうまい〜〜
赤はちょっと辛かった
で、水色はちょっと甘かった
黄緑はスパイスがよかった
全てのいいところが出てます
見なかったら、めちゃくちゃいいですよ
チクショー
大盛り２杯分
残さず食っちまったぜ！
チクショー！！
めちゃくちゃうめぇ！